donc la parole est à monsieur cyril
pelles va pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues ils sont venus vous
les avez vu vous les avez entendu madame
la ministre
comprenez les et réagissez à l'appel de
tous les syndicats de police
tous les personnels de cette institution
déjà dans des agents administratifs aux
commissaires étaient réunis hier devant
votre ministère pour vous exprimer leur
désarroi face à la politique pénale que
vous avez mis en place une manifestation
de cette ampleur n'est pas eu lieu
depuis 14 ans leurs revendications
relatives à leurs conditions de travail
manque de moyens effectifs réduits sont
importantes mais ce n'est pas sur cela
qu'ils veulent avant tout aux
interpellés c'est sur la politique
pénale laxiste du gouvernement c'est là
leur principale revendication
il ne cesse de clamer les délinquants ne
craignent plus la police à peine
interpellé aussitôt relâchés désarroi
injustice absence de considération et
stigmatisations sont les sentiments
ressentis par les forces de police
oui les policiers se sentent abandonnés
oui madame la garde des sceaux
vous êtes l'incarnation de la politique
pénale du gouvernement suppression des
peines planchers contraintes pénale
réductions de peines systématiques
conditions de la légitime défense
inadaptée la prison qui devient
l'exception
le délinquant mieux considérer que la
victime autant de mesures de
contradiction avec le terrain
quatre-vingt mille peines parents ne
sont pas exécutées 1 l'exécution de la
peine est plus assurée face à cette
justice bien trop permissive
beaucoup parlent du divorce police
justice mais il n'est pas trop tard le
dialogue police justice doit être
établir pour le bien de nos concitoyens
de notre république
un changement de politique pénale est
plus que nécessaire madame la ministre
allez vous enfin mettre en place une
politique pénale qui est pour priorité
la sécurité des français par l'exécution
rapide des peines prononcées
je vous remercie merci
la parole est à madame christiane
taubira garde des sceaux pour 2008
monsieur le président mesdames la
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur la circonstance qui
a déclenché l'expression de ce
mécontentement et triste elle inspire de
la gravité mais manifestement vous avez
quelques difficultés à prendre de la
hauteur pour ma part je me sens tenus
par la situation du policier qui
aujourd'hui encore lutte pour la vie je
ne veux pas rappelés dans ces
circonstances qu'il ya eu d'autres
drames de cette nature parce que nous
nous sommes justement toujours interdite
d'instrumentaliser ces tragédies
nous avons toujours fait le choix du
respect le respect de la victime de sa
famille de leur dignité
nous choisissons nous de ne pas nous
défausser quand d'autres jetés en pâture
des magistrats et des fonctionnaires
dans une stratégie de bouc émissaire
nous choisissons ne pas nous défausser
et de voir ce qui convient d'améliorer
c'est ainsi que nous avons déjà
expertise et la loi de 2004 puis de 2004
lorsque vous étiez au pouvoir et les
textes d'application
les textes d'application qui introduit
de la profusion
nous avons déjà entrepris la révision
pour l'amélioration des circuits
d'information des juges d'application
des peines pour qu' il soit totalement
informé lorsqu'il doit prendre une
décision et nous allons veiller à la
publication rapide de ces documents de
ces de ces textes le premier ministre a
dit tout ce qu'il y avait à dire il hier
et ce matin monsieur le sénateur
monsieur le sénateur nous sommes
soucieux de veiller à ce que les
conditions de travail des forces de
sécurité des magistrats au quotidien
sous et permettent d'assurer la sécurité
des français également la protection de
leurs libertés individuelles et de leurs
libertés publiques et nous savons que
c'est dans une relation de confiance sur
le terrain au quotidien
chacun à sa place chacun dans sa mission
que les forces de sécurité et les magic
pour seule conclusion notre sécurité et
la préservation de nos libertés
madame la ministre la parole est à
d'autres collègues
madame mireille jouve pour le groupe du
rassemblement tu as la réplique
pardonnez moi monsieur pulvar
excusez-moi 20 secondes c'est le
président madame la ministre
il est bien trop désir de revenir
éternellement au passé je vous demandais
ce que comptait faire ce que vous
comptez faire actuellement les chers
collègues je la décris la réponse était
attendue c'est toujours la même le rôle
premier de la justice et de faire
appliquer la loi et je compte sur vous
pour le faire merci chers collègues